Richard rainwater is the stellar
financier of our generation
very very few things Richard did in his
life didn't really work out well it was
just a question of how well did they
work out were they a hundred ex were
they 5x
about a lot of X's the art of the deal
Donald Trump excuse me Richard rainwater
once he gets into something he's a
hundred and twenty five percent there
with great passion it's hopefully shade
but part of being good at anything part
of being a good manager you think it's
to love what you do I'm not sure there's
ever been any way that was more excited
about doing deals than Richard lots of
people have to compete with other people
who are really killer bright he finds
ways to bring him on his team he had an
extraordinary ability to judge good
people and then had the genius to let
them go
we like you were backing you we liked
the deal run with it if I had to
summarize any one aspect of Richard it
was the way he would relate to people at
their core when you're with somebody and
you're talking to them be with them and
if you do that then good things happen I
mean he has a way of making people
believe they can do things and they
themselves didn't think they could do
and then people go out and do it one of
the things he says is that you have to
look at scenarios a through Z and most
people only will look at the middle look
at the most probable outcomes
any-any says you got to focus on as he
says friggin Z Z is the one where's the
the big returns
Richard would say a leads to C and that
could compromise F but if we do L the
deal will work and it was always right
he had another saying the first criteria
we have for investing money is to never
lose money the second criteria is to pay
attention to the first criteria Richard
would always say wherever there's chaos
there's opportunity
when everybody's running away from an
opportunity this is where the chaos is
there's got to be a nugget in here
somewhere and when the tide turns not
only will we've found something very
interesting but the the appreciation
potential be huge he brought to the job
every day or at least every day I
witnessed a a sort of a whimsy and a joy
about what he was doing but when we
first bought this office building in
Fort Worth that we owned we rented a
whole floor from ourselves but we only
needed like a third of the floor we had
frisbee games we had golf courses we'd
take you know kids bowling toys and a
bowling contest me Richard would
spontaneously burst in your office at
2:00 in the afternoon and say okay we're
having a bowling tournament over on the
other side of the office and everybody
was there who was working on very
serious things but he had a way of just
making sure everybody was part of the
family and at any given moment would
have to drop things and enjoy life a
little bit I always stay in New York at
the Regency Hotel
and I asked him to come over for
breakfast so there's Henry Kissinger at
this table and James Robinson of
American Express at this table all up in
their three-piece suits Richard shows up
in a baseball cap and a t-shirt he was
just there for breakfast so there's
nothing about appearances that's
important to Richard it's only about
results
richard has never sought self
recognition or aggrandize for the
balance of his career nobody knew who
Richard rainwater was Richard should
have received this award 20 years ago
and then 15 years ago and 10 years ago
but every time any of us proposed it he
would always say no there's somebody
else who's more deserving I haven't done
that much I mean I I might I've been
lucky the Arbuckle award is designed to
inspire people by example and I think
Richards example is one that inspires
all of us the decision as to who would
get the award this year once Richard
said he would do it that was the easiest
decision ever made by the Stanford
business goal I mean look at his
business history and look at the people
that he's been working with and these
friendships have lasted for this 40
years which i think is something all of
us would say is probably one of the most
valuable things if not the most valuable
thing we got out of our degree at
Stanford Business School from a personal
standpoint my life's been tremendously
enhanced by knowing Richard he's
definitely a life enhancer for those
people that he comes in contact with
Richard in creating companies and doing
all these deals brought great
opportunity to so many people I don't
suspect there's anyone who contributed
more and helped Richard more than
Richard helped them that's truly a great
accolade